Look,
I'm hoping that we can spend most of our times a day and discussion rather than
with me just talking on my own.
I've got a few slides because I might want to pull up some couldn't quotations,
um,
not as the basis for a full tour.
But I will say a little to begin.
So I had two basic points.
Um,
first people keep saying that consciousness is a mystery,
but it isn't a matter is mysterious,
but consciousness isn't.
And second point is there's that to literally nothing in science that gives us
any reason to doubt the reality of consciousness or to think that it is anything
other than it's seems.
So if anybody doubts whether either of those two claims is true,
we'll have something to talk about.
But it's very difficult with audiences.
Could you just don't know,
there's increasing tribalism in this debate too is people are very entrenched.
So I don't expect to be able to convince anybody if they've already been led to
think otherwise.
So that's my optimistic prognostic.
But to begin,
most of us who think about consciousness,
he states are committed naturalists.
We don't think that just means we don't think there's anything supernatural or
otherwise.
Non-Natural.
Most of us were also of all out physicalist or materialist studies.
We think that everything in the universe is wholly physical.
And I do myself,
um,
I hope that most of us are also clear on the point that that is color
experience.
Let's see if I've got some kind of absurd that I have to produce some,
but because you are having it already,
but
mmm.
Um,
taste experience and patient experience.
And I hope that most of us,
and I admit,
I don't know how things stand in this room are all are realists about color,
experience,
taste,
and so on.
Just like the other 7.5 billion people on the planet,
we should be realistic because the existence of conscious experience is the most
and
got it.
Something's gone wrong.
I think the most certain,
you know,
in general,
natural,
natural fact about reality,
you can doubt almost anything,
the existence of the external world,
but you can't really doubt the fact that you're having conscious experience
right now.
I know that some,
yes,
that
you hear me.
Yeah,
sorry.
Yeah.
If something's going on and off,
I don't know why
you'll have to bear with me for the moment.
There are familiar thought experiments that make the point that you can doubt
the existence of the external world.
You might for example,
be a focal brain in a vat.
Oh,
okay.
Being fair to seamless world,
uh,
world simulation or if some of you will know,
you might be a wholly computationally realized subject of experience in them in
a Bostrom and Nick Bostrom world simulation and so on.
But you can't doubt that at least it seems to you that you're having experience
right now of seeing me and hearing me talk and for it to seem to you that you're
having experienced just is for you to be having experience.
The seeming is made of experience.
It is already a form of conscious experience.
Well,
I'm using the word I'd like to take it that,
you know what I mean?
When I say consciousness or conscious experience or experience,
I mean the qualitative,
what it is like of everyday experience seeing scarlet or tasting Tahini.
The trouble is that words like consciousness have been full barred in men in so
many different ways in recent discussion that they become almost useless.
Some people have done what I like to call,
they've reversified or looking glass.
The word consciousness where to reversify or looking glass.
A word is to use it in such a way that whatever one means by it,
it excludes what it actually means.
And from where I stand down,
then it has done exactly that.
He has looking glass,
the word consciousness.
Some of you will have come across the word quality.
There's plural qualia,
qualia,
Qualia.
It's used as a general name for all the distinctive what it's likenesses of
experience,
sound experience,
smell,
experience,
taste,
experience of red versus experience of green versus experience of Purple C.
Uh,
and pretty exciting,
Huh?
A headache versus stomachache or nausea.
So on.
It seems to be kind of obligatory dimensional orgasm in these contexts.
So there you are.
I had done my duty,
I've always avoided using the word Qualia,
um,
for various complicated reasons in philosophical debate.
But I'm going to use it now because I think there's less argument about what it
means,
what the argument is about is whether Qualia exist and although I think that's
crazy,
it is at least clear.
I know that a few philosophers deny that qualia exist and that a few
psychologists do and reports have reached me.
That is also true of some people in who work in AI or it take him in the largest
sense where this includes people who work at August institutions like Google.
Well I think,
and I like to say that the denial that Qualia exist,
the denial that consciousness exists where consciousness is understood in the
ordinary sense that denial is the silliest thing that has ever been said in the
whole history of the human race.
In my experience is many philosophers who say this silly thing,
but I'm worried that the habit is spreading and this is what we may have to talk
about.
So here we are rather,
here I am,
I declare myself to be a good naturalist,
passionate naturalist,
a full on no nonsense materialist who thinks that everything in the university
is physical.
Who Thinks of conscious experience is wholly a matter of goings on in the brain
and who also thinks knows for sure that there are qualia experiences and many
different kinds.
And that's the issue.
Some people think that this race is a problem.
They think that you can't be a ride on naturalists,
materialists and at the same time be an all out realist about conscious
experience and Qualia.
Fortunately this isn't so there is no conflict.
There's no conflict of any sort,
no stress,
no tension between being an all our materialist or naturalist as hard nose as
you like and fully acknowledging the reality of conscious experience of Qualia,
of experiential,
what it is like,
but full on stereo,
technicolor,
multimodal show.
The idea that these two things,
material is naturalism and following consciousness are incompatible so that you
can't have both is just a mistake.
It's a very large mistake.
The truth is that you can't really be a naturalist at all.
A real naturalist.
You can't be a remotely realistic naturalist and not acknowledge the existence
of following consciousness.
Why not?
Because it's the most certainly known.
Uh,
and obviously holy natural thing.
There is
a,
so how did anyone ever get to deny the existence of consciousness or Qualia?
Um,
that is made what I believe to be the silliest claim that has ever been made in
the whole history of human thought.
Well,
I really don't want to antagonize anyone.
I don't really see how I can avoid it,
so I may as well now my colors to the mast.
Um,
and you know,
the people that I'm opposed to our philosophy is I just don't know how it is out
there in the real world.
Um,
we need to anatomize this mistake a bit.
It is among other things and perhaps centrally mistake about physics,
about all physical sciences is generally about what physics is and does more
broadly.
It's the mistake of thinking we know more about the nature of the physical world
then we do.
And actually that did,
it is interestingly a recent mistake upon,
among materialists as recently as the 1950s almost no materialists made it.
There were many,
many convinced materialists or physicalist if you like back then how all out
hardnosed materialists with nose as hard as you like stretching back to two and
a half thousand years.
None of them were so foolish as to deny the existence of conscious experience,
the existence of the thing whose existence is more certain than the existence of
anything else.
So as I keep saying,
I'm a materialist myself,
I believe that everything that exists in universities physical,
so buying the physical,
I just mean everything that exists in the universe.
And so of course I think that consciousness is wholly physical.
Um,
Qualia.
I don't think that physics can express or descriptively characterize everything
that exists,
but thinking that is no part of being a materialist.
That's where some people go wrong.
And materialistic again is just someone who thinks that everything that exists
is physical and no one Aye.
Aye.
I propose no one who understands what's physics is thinks that physics can
express or descriptively characterize everything that exists.
This is because they know with,
for example,
Stephen Hawking that physics,
and I quote him,
physics is just a set of rules.
And Equations.
They know that physics has nothing,
absolutely nothing to say to the question of the ultimate intrinsic nature of
the staff that satisfies the rules and equations.
Over and above saying that it satisfies those rules and equations.
They know that physics just isn't in the business of answering the question and
this is Hawkings words again,
the question,
what is it that breathes fire into the equations and makes a universe for them
to describe?
Let me try and get to my,
they know so I want to quote,
Oh,
here he is.
Russell.
I'm very keen on Russell.
It's been forgotten recently,
but he's coming back.
I hope so.
They know with Russell that I quote,
a physics in itself is extremely abstract and reveals only certain mathematical
characteristics of the material with which it deals.
It does not tell us anything as to the intrinsic nature of this material
at moment.
He says,
we realize this abstractness but it doesn't make its do impression because
imagination reassert itself.
As soon as we're off,
our guard here is again matter,
quote marks around.
It is only an is known only as regards certain very abstract characteristics,
which might by physics that is,
which might quite well belonged to a manifold of mental events but might also
belong to a different manifold.
It's necessary to emphasize the Stream Lee abstract character of physical
knowledge and the fact that physics leaves open all kinds of possibilities as to
the intrinsic character of the world to which it's equations apply.
And he says,
I'm interested in the materialism has been guilty unconsciously and in spite of
explicit disavow walls of a confusion in it's imaginative picture of matter.
And I think that that's,
um,
that's afflicts all of us.
Most of us,
most of the time adjust,
not able to overcome that confusion.
We think we can't help thinking we know more about the intrinsic nature of
matter then we do.
Um,
so,
uh,
I think at the Russell is right about the nature of physics.
He's also right that we find it very hard not to slip back into thinking that we
know more than we do about matter.
And then coming to things that matter,
can't be conscious,
can't give rise to consciousness or qualia.
Okay,
well that's a big mistake.
That's a fatal mistake.
The mistake again is to think that we know anything about matter or physical
stuff that generally,
that gives us good reason to think that consciousness,
conscious experience,
Qualia can't be wholly physical.
One point,
I don't know if it's going to come up because I can't control my,
Oh yeah.
Now I've got some rude remarks about philosophers.
Uh,
I'll just leave them up there and,
um,
absolutely true.
All of them.
Uh,
I'm not saying other people are better,
but,
um,
Russell again,
we now realize I'm quoting that we know nothing of the intrinsic quality of
physical phenomena except when they happen to be sensations and that therefore
there is no reason to be surprised at.
Some are sensations.
So there's a very explicit endorsement of the claim that the qualitative,
what it is,
like he's literally physical,
physical stuff.
You could say.
And this is extremely startling if you've had a sort of conventional upbringing.
Um,
when you get this,
when you really get this,
you're on the verge in my view of becoming a real naturalist or real
materialist.
Um,
what are your chances of getting this,
of becoming a real materialist?
Um,
if you've had this conventional upbringing?
I just think they're not great if you've already been tempted to deny
consciousness in any way.
It depends on how open minded you are.
And most of us aren't.
I mean,
I fully admit that I had a kind of revelation 25 years ago when I finally got
it.
Are there so imprinted on this picture of matter as this clunky stuff that is
intrinsically nonconscious?
Uh,
may many of us imprint on what we are taught early on.
We feel the need for closure.
Um,
the psychologist and social psychologists have a nice term for this.
We seize and freeze.
We see some of you and then we freeze out further thought about it.
We polarize and we tribalized with great intensity.
I'm nearly done with,
um,
but people,
I claim,
you know,
something about what physics is now with Addington.
It's very old point that physics has nothing to say about what he calls.
I quote in 1928 the and get actable nature of the physical.
They know this well whether or not they think which Schrodinger for example,
and I quote the material universe and consciousness I made out of the same stuff
or whether they think with Max Planck for example,
a quote that consciousness is fundamental and matter is derivative from
consciousness.
I'm not sure I put it that way or whether they know with the debris,
the wave function guy,
I quote that consciousness and matter a different aspects of one and the same
thing I quote again,
he the boy this,
the aspect of this substance that we examined by scientific methods is what we
call matter.
The other aspect of which we obtain knowledge,
not scientifically,
but directly is what we call consciousness.
And Lawrence with whom Einstein fully agrees says,
and I quote the mental and the material of two sides of the same thing.
And the key here is that physics and being just a set of rules of equations.
It doesn't rule that out in any way.
And since we know there's consciousness,
the door is now wide open for us to,
to reconcile.
Okay.
Uh,
this mistake has gone very deep in some people.
And I mean characteristically when you got used to a certain use of word or a
certain way of thinking,
you just can't really hear the other view.
Um,
and some people,
there's also a kind of rebellious attraction to the deny the existence of
consciousness in one way or another.
You kind of feel brave or heroic or intellectually fearless.
Um,
well that's fine.
But I think it's also sad because you're really so lost when you do that.
Uh,
okay,
look,
I'm just going to stop and I'm going to hope someone has some objection or tells
me I'm wrong or something.
Yeah.
Good.
I can do that.
And I've read some Dennett and he was here a while back and mirrored him talk.
Yeah.
And uh,
I don't necessarily feel qualified to like state his position.
Um,
at least from what I've read and what I've heard from him.
I feel like he talks a lot about certain specific things that people take for
granted as part of their conscious experience and often does it makes a strong
case that they're not quite true,
even if it goes to forest,
a lack of quality.
Yeah.
It's like,
for example,
I subjectively experienced my life is continuous.
I subjectively experience myself as a single entity,
but you can quibble a lot about what it means to be a single entity if there's
no point where all information,
you know,
it kind of comes together and you can quibble a lot about the continuity of
conscious experience when it shuts off every night or when you know,
it like parts of my brain kind of like reset and start over every few minutes.
And I feel like that's to some degree,
that's the stronger element of his are to say about that.
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
I use that a lot of things that I'm not sure if they couldn't remember them all
already.
But,
um,
I mean you were saying you're a biological single thing,
right?
So that's when you said that it's somehow allude what you meant,
right.
It's about,
about like the me being like a single entity.
Yes.
So it's more about the fact that like the brain is,
you know,
really heavily distributed.
So like I experienced myself as in like a very narrative form of like I'm a
person,
I make decisions,
I take actions.
Yeah,
no,
I'm actually on the issue of that as it were,
that narrative conceptions of self being very much construction.
I actually felt deeply agree with Dennis and I think he's very subtle and
interesting about that.
Uh,
but I really,
I really like to restrict it as much as possible to the really basic issue,
which is just qualia.
Because I would say that,
I mean,
I don't know whether any of you know,
but I wrote a piece lots month on the New York review blog,
um,
say say about the silliest claims,
the denial contracts and Dennett replied about 10 days ago.
And then I replied to him,
we had,
and I,
I think I've gathered enough quotations,
I think to show that he does.
He's right.
He's,
he's an extremist in the sense that he denies the existence of qualitative
character of the sort that I'm claiming that I know you have when I get up one
of those colors.
And again,
I want to say something like I shouldn't have,
it's silly in a way that I'm doing this bringing up a color because I've
actually got a a spray out.
If I was,
I'm tempted to kind of spray a certain
odor,
I mean a nice one in the room and then see that,
get you to recognize it and then ask you how you did that.
But I won't.
Um,
so can we keep to that?
So
do you think you can give a,
are really like precise definition of like how you,
are you,
are you in Denny using the same definition for the term Kalia and like can be
really precise about what that definitely,
I think we are,
that's why I mean would definitely not use it.
We definitely define consciousness in different ways because he,
I mean,
I could,
I would,
I I'd like to try and pull up some quotations.
He famously says,
look,
in his reply to me,
I could read you some quotations.
He says,
I quote Dennett,
I don't deny the existence of consciousness.
Of course consciousness exists.
It just isn't what most people think it is.
Um,
but he also says things like,
do you know what?
Does everyone know what a Zombie is?
In the,
in the,
in the sort of semi technical philosophical sense,
a Zombie is a creature that is outwardly and behaviourally indistinguishable
from a normal human being but has no consciousness in the,
in what we think,
what I think of as the everyday sense.
And then at one point says we're all zombies.
That is,
we,
there is really no in our what it is like there at all.
Uh,
for him,
consciousness is just a functional term.
It means you're very,
you know,
you see the velocity raptor.
If it comes at you,
you go through the door in the right kind of way.
Consciousness is awareness of your surroundings of the thought that in principle
a super duper robot could have.
He's,
I think he's unequivocal about that.
So we don't,
we completely disagree.
When we used with consciousness.
I think he then,
but he,
that's why I liked the term qualia because he'd finds it quite carefully,
um,
as the kind of touchy feely real thing that I mean and I'm sure I believe you
will know what I mean.
And then he says that doesn't exist.
That's an illusion.
That's his word.
So are you willing to go with him there quite go.
I'm going to yield to this guy for a bit.
Yeah.
Briefly.
Do you them,
do you think that this is related to the distinction between being and becoming
or static or dynamic?
Like there's salt and the saltiness.
Salt is sodium and chloride.
Saltiness isn't a thing you can put your finger on.
I don't,
I don't actually think I hadn't ordered,
it never occurred to me.
Um,
I do want one,
I talk about quality of character.
I,
I do really want to mean the thing that's actually live occurrent clockable
happening right now to you.
So there is a more abstract notion of,
you know,
SAP green or whatever that is is that it's more like saltiness,
but I really want does that correspond to told what I was meaning for example is
people could say there's as farm say 700 nanometer wavelength.
Yeah.
Right.
And there's what I'm feeling when I personally look at it.
So I wasn't thinking of that either.
Of course.
I mean I agree that if you want to give 'em as it were a scientific definition
of color,
you're going to do it in terms of a surface reflectance properties.
And actually the,
the physics of color and reflecting is incredibly got weird and complicated.
But,
um,
I wasn't thinking of that.
I'm really only talking about the subjective qualitative,
what it is like that you have.
And of course it's a fun,
it's a famous and familiar thought experiment.
Let me do my,
let me ask you,
how many people is,
kids wondered,
ever wonder whether when they looked at something like that,
someone else,
one of their friends was having a qualitatively different experience and give me
some hand.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
you're actually,
when I asked classes about this,
I get about 50% I think I got slightly more.
So it must be a sort of nerd thing.
Okay.
But some,
so you don't think that that kind of distinction is one of the reasons for this
error or how would it,
how would it work?
It's like saying for example,
they're like,
well I don't think quality exists because there's not some atoms or something.
What is it?
It's some process or what do you mean by that?
I see.
Okay.
That's,
there are so many problems with words.
Um,
all I mean is you're having a certain experience right now.
It,
and it,
it is clockable it's happening in these,
during these seconds and it has a certain quality of character and that isn't
abstract in any way.
It's just part of the,
the beating of your experience.
It's real.
It's concrete.
Totally concrete.
So that's how I would reply.
And I would hope that they are,
I don't know what the other person,
the other person would say at that point,
but I just mean that,
I mean the,
the real happening thing,
the thing that's happening to a baby.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
so back to Dennett,
uh,
he was here and I directly confronted him about this.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Yes.
Uh,
so I asked him about,
um,
well,
I,
I sort of led into this,
but I asked him about panpsychism.
Oh.
And so his answer was,
and like,
you know,
I paraphrase a little bit,
but he,
he said,
um,
I almost believe it,
except I want to change the word psyche too nifty.
Like I believe in pen nifty ism.
Every atom is nifty.
And so,
you know,
he's sort of demonstrating that,
uh,
if we claim that everything in the universe has some quality,
like everything is conscious,
then there's no sort of descriptive power in that statement.
So that,
that was his quote,
his kind of objection.
It's a perfectly reasonable thing to say.
But the thing is,
I do think that he exemplifies what I call the very large mistake.
Um,
there's another sentence in which I quoted in my reply to him,
which is he says,
um,
so first of all there's a argument,
we'd say it,
I,
um,
you don't really see green,
you just seem to see green and that he has made that move.
And then someone says,
but what's seeming to see green?
Like,
and the answer to that is it's just like seeing green.
So you,
you can't escape by saying it's only a seeming.
So he then,
this is like 25 years ago,
he then responded to that by saying,
I quote,
if materialism is true,
there are no real seemings.
So,
so he,
I mean I sound,
I'm sure it was the light for what he said about nifty in us,
but he has the problem that he thinks that if materialism is true,
you cannot really have a qualia.
And,
and that I say is the big mistake because physics simply is silent on the issue
of the ultimate intrinsic nature of stuff.
And I do,
I am sympathetic to send psych is Criner kind of hoping to leave this,
leave it out of this,
but because I feel like it puts me at a sort of tactical disadvantage if I
confess that I'm attracted to pans cycles because everyone thinks well that's
just wacky or something.
Um,
but actually it's not new agey.
I think it's,
it's actually where hard material of them need to.
But Hi,
I'm slightly losing my track here.
But the thing is that if you think that materialism rules out real seemings or
um,
uh,
well,
then you have to deny the existence of that.
And I think what I'm saying we'd like to say to him is,
you don't have to deny it.
You've made a mistake about what physics says and what physics rules out.
Right.
Is that clear enough?
It makes sense.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you very much.
I wanted to ask or talk a little bit about the relationship between
consciousness and AI because I think that's a big debate.
These issues and my understanding of a lot of people's perception of AI and just
whether or not computers can be conscious is it's in part due to this belief
that not only can math describe reality,
it also has the ability to generate reality.
And in some sense,
I don't know if I'm using this term correctly,
but I think it's based on a notion of Cartesian dualism where there's this
substrate of reality and then the mind is a mathematical abstraction on top of
it or
no.
So I
well may have flushed out the thought.
Um,
so I suppose I'm just wondering if you think there is at least this a important
distinction between one,
whether or not the mind is a mathematical abstraction on top of reality.
And in that case,
math has the ability to generate first person reality versus whether or not the
mind and consciousness are one in the same with the substrate of reality.
And if you think that's,
I'm a bit lost.
Um,
I think I take it the maths in itself.
Math is wholly an abstract thing.
It hasn't,
has no concrete,
um,
realities.
So,
but you know,
a conscious state this,
this is,
it's not if you like,
it's not in time.
So whereas your copy,
your current conscious experience of green here is um,
it's concrete and must be something more than merely mathematical.
So,
so I,
I guess I just want to draw that to the complete,
I've heard this line of thought and I mean if anyone can develop it at all,
it would be helpful because,
um,
I don't,
the thing I need a bridge because I didn't see that one can just say the mind is
just mathematics because mathematics is abstract.
It's like,
think of,
think of a book that just has,
you know,
all the equations and Physics and it technically,
theoretically speaking,
that that's an abstract structure which could be realized by many different
sorts of things.
Just as a,
you know,
a computer program could,
could apply to the sort of tidal flow round some islands or to the Panamanian
Maconomy.
It doesn't,
you see what I mean?
It needs to,
it,
it's got to be concretized before.
So I,
I think I agree with you.
I just wanted to,
I think a lot of people believe AI can be conscious,
I think.
Well,
well what do you mean?
You mean a built thing?
Running a,
so computers are fundamentally mathematical abstractions.
Oh yeah.
This,
I'm sorry,
I'm sort of,
I probably unsympathetic to your language because I'm a sort of,
I've been trained in philosophy.
I,
uh,
it's an odd thing to say that they're concrete objects.
You can kick them there.
They're not mathematical extractions.
They have programs.
Uh,
and even those are fully,
you know,
there,
there's hardware.
Uh,
so can you really express it in some way that I can,
sorry,
at least in,
I think the debate of consciousness takes many forms depending on the fields
you're in.
And at least in the world of computer science,
I think there's often a discussion on whether or not math as an entity
can generate what we want,
what we call consciousness and yeah.
But I'm very doubtful about truth of that statement,
but I think a lot of people in the world of AI believe it.
Yeah.
Does that mean someone's got to flesh that out?
Because Matt,
you said you've taught it but talked about it as an entity.
Well,
I say it's an abstract entity.
Um,
in the sense I've,
all that mathematical truths existed before the universe existed,
if it ever did not exist or would exist if there wasn't a universe.
Um,
whereas consciousness,
these are states of these are these alive occurrent,
clockable concrete happenings.
So math abstract things can't generate concrete things.
You can build things that do things because they run programs that can be,
that have abstract descriptions.
So,
you know,
this is sort of philosophical quibbling,
but I think it's really important.
Um,
anyway,
I'm glad to hear you're sympathetic.
I'm sure you've heard of the Mary's room argument.
Yes.
Nonphysical information.
And I was wondering as a materialist what
yeah,
I just wouldn't a paper about why I think it's been a big waste of time,
but it's been very convincing for me and I'm wondering for you,
okay,
what the,
your uh,
oh,
which way were you convinced?
Convinced by the original argument,
Mary,
a good that Mary somehow is missing some information and something new by you
can reiterate it.
The argument for that.
Yeah,
I will try to,
it's very simple.
Um,
actually
this is a thought experiment,
um,
published in 1982 by a guy called Frank Jackson,
but actually I've done some research.
It's a very old idea.
I quite actually,
uh,
what the idea is that it's completely sort of fantastic and unrealistic and a
typical philosophical way,
Mary is this libs has lived all her life in a black and white room and she has
no color experience.
She's nether,
she's got normal color vision,
but she's never seen any,
she's never seen anything red.
She's never seen anything other than black and white.
But she's a super scientist.
She has a complete grasp of physics and of neurophysiology.
And she knows if she looked at your brain with a sort of super brain scanner and
saw the stadium was in,
she'd be able to say he is seeing right now and,
and,
but she's never experienced red herself.
And then in the story she walked out of the room and wow,
she says red for the first time and she learns something new.
That's,
but there are a lot of people who've pushed back against that and saying,
no,
she hasn't learned anything new.
She knew everything there was to know when she knew the complete physics and
neurophysiological story about what was going on in your brain.
I hope that you all agree with me and him that she did learn something new,
but did you want to develop that?
Is that sufficient description?
Okay,
so do I just have,
I cannot really defend the other side because I think it's so obvious that she
learns something new and yeah,
but you should know I took it to mean there that there exists nonphysical
information and yeah.
Oh good.
Okay.
Now,
so the issue here is that you think that's nonphysical and I say good.
Yeah.
And I've been saying everything's physical.
Yeah,
no,
what I'm saying,
it's not physics.
This is the people who say that she doesn't learn anything new are precisely the
people who think that it's part of their view that physics must give a full
characterization of everything.
And I think that is just obviously false.
And I don't think you,
I don't,
I'd like to bet you won't find many physicists to think that they get it.
And it was a commonplace,
commonplace a hundred years ago that,
you know,
physics gives this highly abstract characterization and leaves open the question
of the stuff,
the stuff that concretely realizes the abstract structures.
Um,
so,
so I would,
okay,
it,
it turns on how you understand the word physical.
You're right,
that it's quite a common understanding of the physical,
the word physical that you'd say she gets some nonphysical information.
But I want to say thinking of it like that is what is the very thing that puts
up the barrier that makes it seem there's a terrible problem actually.
Color experience is,
uh,
is it self also a holy physical phenomenon,
but it's not covered by physics.
So that would be my own,
I think we agree,
but using different terminology.
Yeah,
no,
but it was helpful because you're quite right that people might want to say the,
as it were,
the information that you get just in looking at the green is if somehow a supra,
physical or nonphysical,
but then as soon as you've said that you,
you're,
you're locked into the old problem and you,
you're going to have to think,
and if you're a tough physically is to going to have to think,
oh,
that can't really exist.
And I'm trying to say,
no,
it's all right.
You can fully believe in this.
This is also a physical,
it's just not the kind of thing that physics talks about.
Uh,
and that's,
it's not,
um,
uh,
new agey or I'm not being hard nosed enough,
to,
to say that that's a physical because no one who gets what physics does thinks
that physics ought to be able to describe that.
Hey,
so I'm a,
I've been thinking lately about,
um,
why,
why computer scientists in general tend to resist this type of argument.
And I think,
yes,
do the,
I don't know.
I,
I wonder,
um,
whether,
it has to do with the fact that the cook purely qualitative nature of color
experience like this,
um,
is,
you know,
completely independent of whatever like mathematical description of the three
dimensional color space and it's pointed in that space.
Um,
and we're very used to thinking that physics and computation are,
you know,
equivalent in power and does computation is everything and this math is
everything.
It's this thing that we actually have to resist in the other direction with a
lot of discussions with,
you know,
a non computer scientists.
Um,
but just,
I don't know,
I wonder if you've come up with a good way of getting people to recognize the
fact that any given three dimensional space that describes human color
experience and this particular color is pointed in that space is completely
independent of the fact that that's the color experience I'm having right now.
Like there's,
there's still this concrete,
purely qualitative,
non describable only pointable at reality in that,
in that color experience.
Well,
um,
I'm not Joe,
you said three dimensional.
You meant as it were,
abstract state space,
RGB or HSV or,
yeah,
but it could also be,
I mean,
if it's true,
that sound is just a matter of what does it Tambre pitch.
What's the other thing?
It's also three dimensional I think so.
I mean I think that would make the point that as it were,
the Pune is structural description doesn't even tell you whether the quality
space,
um,
okay,
this is,
this is a node as it were in a state space and so his middle c played on an
oboe.
Um,
and let's imagine that they're there by some men,
some sort of calculation at the same space,
but the abstract description hasn't given you the,
the,
the stuffy,
the stuff.
He bit the qualities of character.
Um,
and you need that as soon as you move from the abstract description to anything
concrete at all.
So,
so the,
the,
as it were,
I put in my challenge on my word right at the beginning of what you said,
where you said some,
you said things like math is everything.
Our competition is everything.
I mean,
and obviously don't believe that.
No,
I know.
Yeah.
No you
don't.
I know you don't believe it,
but,
well,
I don't know if anyone else wants to defend this.
The,
Oh,
okay.
This kind of position.
Oh,
someone's jumping up there.
Um,
you gotta be Rick.
Uh,
okay.
Do you want to try it?
Sure.
Well,
I don't know if I'm qualified to defend anything.
I just had a like possibly clarifying questions.
So when you say physical,
I think a lot of people are talking about like reducible,
so like is are these quality,
uh,
you're saying they are basic,
they can't be decomposed into other things that we might be able to figure out
or like is Qualia,
is consciousness reducible to two?
Like maybe some very basic things like
you know,
like,
like that kind of thing and like,
um,
and then I guess you can also like sort of use that perspective on Mary and the
room where she,
obviously her brain is in a different state where she learns the things about
like all the equations of color that goes in one place and then the experience
does change a different part of your brain.
Right?
Like the memory of seeing green versus the memory of the equations are stored
completely differently.
It's obviously a completely different thing,
but like with the information,
you can build a machine that will give him the state space.
You can show it on the screen and then get that part of your brain of the
experience.
Right.
I think,
uh,
are you telling me,
I'm saying that,
um,
is this,
the divide in the room might just be like a how your brain is organized thing,
not a,
it's new information.
There's a very easy way to transform the state space into experience is the like
a projector,
you know,
or,
or uh,
you can have a speaker that will play the oboe sound given the description and
then you get the experience.
That's all fine.
Yeah.
So it's,
I think to say it's new information.
Is it stored in a different place in your brain?
Perhaps?
Well,
but it's not like new information.
You can't,
it's not something like that that you can move it there.
There's a kind of
associative load on the word inflammation,
which makes one think of it as,
as it were somehow really computational or something.
And I'm using it in a large sense.
In fact,
we don't even,
we didn't even use the word information in the description of the case.
We just said she learns something new,
something she did not know,
which is what it is like to see red.
I'm going to,
and I'm going to stick with that because it would you want to challenge that?
I would it depending on what you mean by learn something new.
I would agree that her brain does something it's never done before.
I hope you haven't been corrupted by philosophers.
I've only read like some pop hop step.
Um,
yeah.
I think she learns a new fact about reality,
which is what it is like to see red,
which he didn't know even though she had the super physics on the super
neurophysiology.
Yeah.
It's just your daddy's irreducible.
Right.
So I fully believe that having the right experiences simply neural goings on.
But when I say that,
I don't mean anything.
Like what most people say when they say it's neuro goings on because they,
they think to say that is to be taste something reductive is to say it's nothing
but,
or it's nothing over and above.
But I'm saying neuro goings on are much more interesting than you thought
because near this experience to you having a look at is neuro goings on.
So wake up to the extraordinariness of matter,
right?
That's what,
that's what the messages matter.
This is matter does this one didn't know that.
I mean the brain is 70 what,
77% water or something.
It's 99% hydrogen,
oxygen,
nitrogen and carbon.
I think these are things are more interesting than you for these elements that
I think the reduction question is also a fascinating,
like how,
how does it,
I don't think,
well that's the start of a question.
Well,
it's true.
That is another kind of deep root of the feeling that consciousness can't be
physical.
So if we want to think that everything's physical,
we're going to have to deny consciousness in the end.
Um,
a lot of people,
a lot of people think that this does lead to panpsychism is actually in
escapable.
Um,
but you know,
I like to say that that's because it has to be,
has to be part of the truth.
Uh,
so a lot of people think that the ultimate little bits,
let's just say that leptons and corks,
although I believe that leptons and quotes are just theoretical posits really,
there aren't really things like that.
We think for sure.
Well,
there can't be in any way conscious in consciousness involving,
so how did we,
how could your vivid,
well,
the Google colors experience,
how could that reduce the activity of Leptons and quotes?
No,
Adam is a cat,
but you can still get a cat by putting a lot of them together.
Right?
Yeah,
that's true.
But you see,
the idea is that that's kind of easy is just assembling the bits in a certain
way.
Whereas consciousness seems like a leap into a different quality to domain
altogether.
I agree that it's,
it's,
it does feel different.
Yeah.
No,
we know it isn't.
But suppose I gave you the choice between two theories.
One is that the ultimate little bits are totally and utterly had nothing.
Nothing in any may consciousness like about them.
And on the other view they do.
And we,
if you are someone who thinks it's all in the brain as I do,
um,
which theory do you prefer?
The theory whereby as it were,
the technicolor of real experience arises from little totally nonconscious
things in a certain arrangement or that it arises from things that already
somehow conscience.
It's involving,
I think if you had,
if you have the part of the theory that explains how that happens,
like if you can say what patterns,
Oh yeah.
If I had the that then the part that has no extra basic quality,
uh,
is a simpler theory.
Right.
It seems to,
okay.
That's a very common,
and I totally respect that view.
Yeah.
Flyers that you would have to explain how right.
Like without explaining it.
Yeah.
And that is known as the explanatory gap and it's thought to be uncrossable.
I'm not mean it's uncomfortable then you're done.
But it may be okay.
I want to say one thing there,
which is just that nearly everybody thinks it's kind of wildly,
theoretically extravagant to kind of s to lather consciousness all over the
place.
They think that's,
but actually w one of the things you get,
I hope when you really think about this is not actually it's a,
it's a prejudice or an assumption to think that that's more extravagant than
supposing that the ultimate staff is non consciousness involving,
um,
they're just on a par.
Um,
and then there's one more move that you can make with which probably alienating
people here,
but really things that I,
I know these are new agey,
but they're not,
I keep saying that.
Um,
which now I've forgotten what it was.
So,
uh,
oh yeah.
Um,
what was it?
Gone.
Okay.
Chloric
yeah.
Um,
I was wondering if he could just say a little bit more about this intrinsic
characteristic of matter that Russel talked about.
I think you've caught it staffing and a couple of times,
is it like,
can we in principle figure out what it is?
Is it like the of things that are unfalsifiable empirically?
Like,
what are we talking about?
No,
I can't.
Um,
yeah,
and some people would say if I know,
I think,
I think we can't and I think it was a matter of principle physics,
certainly physics or all sciences that require as it were,
pub public accessibility of data and check ability and um,
independent confirmation.
Um,
it,
it can't be done.
The argument that it's there is,
is simple and I've already given it to him one form,
which is just a,
so he's,
suppose you've got the super final physics with its,
with its beautiful equations and
uh,
and,
and they're right
now you need some stuff.
You need some stuff to be the thing,
the of which they are true.
You've got to move from the abstract to the concrete.
Uh,
and so the argument that there must be some intrinsic nature over and above as
it were,
the physics descriptions of what charges or masses or,
um,
it is simply that the world is real.
Um,
it's not just mathematical structure.
So you could say it's like the real,
like the realized rules of physics that have the additional property that they
exist.
If you can call it existence,
the first order predicate or is it oh hey.
So it's like the anti shooting some philosophy
like the intrinsic nature is the fact that it exists or it's,
oh,
it's a little more than that because a lot of people think that numbers exist so
that,
um,
it's,
it's just,
you know,
concrete stuff that's um,
you cannot,
the Churchill descriptions are true.
He Equals Mc squared,
the inverse square law of gravitation there.
There's something out there that makes them true and it's all cannot be just
structure.
It must be something more and,
but it is in,
it is not something that we could get at.
And this is where people like Russell and Eddington say,
the thing I liked,
the only clue we have as to the ultimate intrinsic nature of stuff is in having
conscious experience.
Um,
so adding to someone who says,
well,
in that case,
why you just assumed that the rest of the stuff isn't in any way,
anything to do with consciousness.
That's the,
that is the theoretically extravagant move,
not the other way around.
It's quite neat.
Okay.
Professor.
Um,
so I'm very sympathetic to your basic point,
which I understand as consciousness is undeniable.
So if there's a problem with one of our physicalism or consciousness and support
with our physical theory or consciousness,
it's a problem with our physical theory.
Yeah.
Plus saying that there isn't a problem.
There's nothing in physics.
Right.
What,
what I'm confused by is I guess how you use the,
the term where the identity physicalist cause it starts to sound a little bit
like a catchall for everything.
I actually is absolutely right.
I mean that's a conscious,
that's a decision.
I mean you're quite right,
but what do I mean by physical?
I just mean everything that's coming quickly in real and you might think I've
tutored in some way or that's not helpful to my question.
To put a point on it is,
is there any sort of experience that you can imagine having that would cause you
to change that identity and say Ohio was an idealist this whole time?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's really,
yeah.
I mean,
maybe this isn't that this is perhaps what I'm in some of what I've been saying
is more appropriate in a,
in an audience of philosophers because that is exactly right that I wouldn't,
well wait idealism,
that's a tricky term because it's nothing like nothing to do.
Some of you will have heard of Bishop Barclay who thinks that tables and chairs
of just ideas in our minds and it's nothing to do with that.
It's if you like,
even when it says no,
the ultimate staff of which everything is made,
which is just kind of on one view,
it's just sort of energy.
It's just buzzing humming energy.
It says the alternator of that stuff which we can't get at,
um,
is somehow already consciousness involving.
So,
uh,
that if you want to extend the word idealism to cover that and I'm going to
agree with you.
Yeah.
It's a kind of,
so it's a kind of,
it's not a magical trick,
but it certainly playing with the words.
I'm going to say
the true physicalism is if you like a kind of idealism and I'm not the first who
said that.
Um,
adding turn.
These also have entertained it.
Um,
I quoted shredding or in plank and um,
the broiler and Lawrence and it's uh,
yeah,
it's um,
so,
and I am not,
but I think it's valuable to try and take the word physical,
which has been sort of saying no,
you've got to think harder about it.
It's not just what physics does cause it.
Is it more about staying in conversation with the scientific community are sort
of using the Commonweal?
I mean,
we know,
given my narrow little concerns,
I'm more concerned with the philosophers and how they talk and I think they're
the ones who've gone most wrong.
I've also got a quotation from my
local Nobel laureate,
Steven Weinberg back in ut Austin where I come from.
He says,
you know,
he said,
I don't know what my fellow physicist think,
but I know that consciousness,
he was real,
you know,
he is a very long way from thinking that being committed to physics and
physicalism raises any ground for any kind of doubt about the reality of
consciousness.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Talking with us is your approach to materialism and consciousness.
Anything about freewill and,
sorry,
what was the beginning?
That's right.
Does your approach to materialism and consciousness imply anything about free?
Well,
does it imply anything?
Uh,
I don't think so.
My view,
I certainly,
I think whatever views I have about freewill are completely independent of that
position.
So because I think they're a priority that in the sense that means you know,
that they don't depend on empirical claims at all.
Uh,
who do you want to develop that at all?
Maybe I'll just ask what,
can you summarize your views do I do,
I have to,
I want to take the fifth.
Um,
I'm listening.
There's a,
there's a very strong natural notion of what free will is given which I think
it's not possible.
Um,
but I don't think that's a problem for our ordinary everyday practices,
which assume freewill and moral responsibility.
I also think that although the argument that it's not,
I could even give it to you if do you want it?
I'll give him really fast.
He goes,
well,
we do what we do because of the way we are
building all the complications of circumstance,
step two.
Um,
so to be truly responsible for what we do,
we've got to be responsible to be responsible for how we are.
Because what we do flows from Amia.
But step three,
you can't be ultimately responsible for how you are.
Why not?
Because roughly you'd have to be the cause of yourself.
You'd have to be there already to make yourself the way you are.
But then you'd have been there already and you'd have to take another step.
So you get what's called an infinite regress argument.
You could never,
as it were,
get back behind yourself in order to create yourself in order to be truly
responsible for how you are and how you act.
And if you look at that argument,
it is purely a priority.
It's got nothing to do with physics.
It doesn't matter whether the determinism is true or determinism is false.
Okay.
I would actually want to say one more thing about that,
which is that although I think that the argument is,
are unanswerable the argument against this very strong notion of free,
well,
I also think that there are,
we cannot help experiencing ourselves as radically free inaction.
I think you can show why.
Okay.
Sorry.
Actually I have two questions or one of them was one of us asked earlier and I'm
not sure it was fall I answered so I'll get back to that in a second.
But,
so you mentioned that you think that consciousness,
so it sounds like you're saying that maybe consciousness is an intrinsic
property that even,
you know,
like it goes down to the level of the quarks or whatever and I'm a little
confused as to what that means.
And you said for example that uh,
it would be really strange.
I'm not sure strangers strange the word you use,
but that,
that if we were conscious but we are made up of things that aren't conscious,
but like a television,
you know,
takes a signal and broadcast and image to people's eyes.
It's made up of things that individually do not do that
good.
Yup.
Yeah.
This is,
this is the whole issue of emergence where emergent properties,
which are broadly defined as they're not there at one level and then they are,
they're at another level.
And this,
the,
the favorite example of that is liquidity.
So an individual water molecule isn't liquid,
but when you put a lump them together,
um,
you've got liquid,
you've got liquidity,
there are a lot,
obviously lots of such properties.
Uh,
what people do is as it were,
that's kosher emergence that summer that's emergence that we can make sense of
and understand.
Uh,
the idea is,
and this is a key issue here,
you're quite right.
Um,
but let me just insert one thing,
which is that the main things I've been wanting to say about how being a
materialist doesn't mean you have to be doubtful about consciousness.
That's independent of the psych psyches bit that wants to put consciousness
right down at the bottom of things.
Okay.
So that was just an insertion.
But going back to the issue of emergence,
uh,
your quite right,
you get properties emerging.
When you put small,
as it were,
crudely small bits together,
you get bigger things would have completely different properties.
Th Th th the I the intuition is the idea is that
cases like liquidity and not problematic,
but the idea that consciousness could emerge from the radically and artfully and
holy nonconscious is problematic.
It's,
it's as it were,
a leap into a different domain in a way in which the other cases aren't.
Why is that?
Why is that know the answers in one and not the other.
Yeah.
And the truth is that when it's not really possible to pursue dizzy fi,
the notion of radical emergent.
So it's a very good question,
uh,
in,
in the,
there is no in a knockdown argument for it.
Um,
so you're quite right.
And I mean,
I've had this objection recently that someone saying they use the example of
heat saying,
you know,
you've got these individual bits and they don't have it.
And then you put the new speed them all up and you've got heat.
And why is it,
why is the alleged emergence of consciousness from the utterly nonconscious
worse or different?
And I,
at that point,
it's a kind of standoff and I say,
I see it,
it's very intuitive.
Let me see if I can,
I might be able to get a one slide here.
I don't know how much time we have left.
I'm sorry about this.
I'm hoping it'll come.
Yeah.
So William James,
um,
this is from his prints.
So continuity,
it doesn't,
uh,
the demand for continuity has over large tracts of science proved itself to
possess true prophetic par.
We ought therefore ourselves sincerely to try every possible mode of conceiving
the dawn of consciousness so that it may not appear or equivalent to the
eruption,
into the universe of a new nature,
nonexistent until them mainly to call the consciousness.
NASA will not serve our turn.
It's true that the word signifies not yet quite born.
And so it seems to form a sort of bridge between the existence and non entity.
But this is a verbal quivell.
The fact is that this continuity comes in.
If a new nature comes in at all,
the quantity of the latter is quite a material,
then he makes a quite a nice joke.
The girl in Midshipman easy could not excuse the illegitimacy of her child by
saying it was a very small one.
And consciousness,
however small is an illegitimate birth in any philosophy that starts without it.
And yet professors to explain all facts by continuous evolution.
So that's the,
that's the intuition and not an argument.
Right.
And I've tried to follow our entirely the argument that because consciousness,
if consciousness is not a characteristic of small things,
that for it to emerge is impossible because there would be discontinuous or,
yeah,
it's just the same.
It's just,
no,
it's just,
it's an eloquent expression of the intuition.
And I use that word as a kind of saying it's not an argument,
but it's very compelling.
It knows that nowhere in the whole of sciences we have it.
Do we have to postulate radical con this continuity's and it does look like any
passage from the ethylene unconscious to something conscious is a radical leap.
Um,
so there's a strong theoretical reason to doubt it.
There's not,
it's not a knockdown argument.
Uh,
and that's just a nice expression of it,
I think.
Yeah.
I mean the other,
this guy,
but I'm just real quick before I,
I do someone asked earlier basically if a computer program can be conscious and
I think,
I think you got into a discussion about mathematics at some point.
It'd be cool if you could return to the question of whether a program could
experience quality,
right?
Nope.
Uh,
program.
Um,
what shall I do?
Shall I say something?
Try and say something about that.
You can come back to it later.
Okay.
Is there another question?
Wait,
can I try to add to the point that this point about sort of,
uh,
the,
um,
I don't know how to describe this point actually,
but you can,
you know,
you can experiment with human brains.
You can like sever human brains,
right?
Like the split brain problem in,
in which case,
you know,
what seems to appear is like to independently functioning consciousnesses or,
or,
right.
And I think that's an important point that if you can sort of physically divide
an object and it's still like has conscious properties,
uh,
and,
I mean,
I dunno,
this is subtle.
Like it,
it both appears to be a single being and appears to be two separate beings
because,
uh,
you can do psychological experiments showing that,
that there is no information passing between the two halves of the brain,
but they're making inferences,
uh,
in such a way that it kind of appears to function like a single person.
That I think sort of by that route you have to conclude that,
that,
you know,
consciousness arises from small things.
So coming into a bigger,
a conscious entity.
Yeah.
I mean I think we might all agree about that,
but yeah,
ponder the issue here is whether,
what do we think the small things are like and uh,
part of what I'm doing.
Do you want to,
um,
part of what I've been saying is simply that,
well,
yeah.
So what the argument was,
the issue I was just discussing was whether there was a difference between
thinking that the small things with themselves utterly nonconscious and thinking
that they were already somehow in consciousness involving,
and I was saying there's no reason to favor the standard view that they have no
sort of consciousness because it creates this huge theoretical problem.
Uh,
but I,
I just agree with everything you've said and it seems to support the right,
the general view that consciousness can be heavily physical.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
so I,
I kind of just want you to,
uh,
articulate,
um,
well there's two defenses of consciousness.
I feel like I've noticed in this talk,
I want you to articulate the first one and then to maybe address like a possible
counter argument to the second.
The first is,
uh,
seems to be that,
um,
science,
any,
anything we know about the world is his first perceived.
And then like everything else we know about it,
even the fact that there's physics,
that things are physical,
that there's,
uh,
you know,
everything else comes from,
uh,
things that we've,
patterns we've inferred from,
uh,
data that we originally perceived from,
being conscious.
That's true.
But I didn't think she used that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I mean that feels very defensive when it seems like you,
uh,
you accept that as a good reason to take it as like a axiom.
Yeah.
Uh,
philosophy.
Um,
and the second one seems unrelated,
it entirely,
but the,
it's the fact of that you're a disability of consciousness on which this
addresses too.
And I wonder if you could explain that as kind of a definitional problem.
Consciousness is,
as we understand it,
just like the full feed of perceptual,
um,
information being received at any given moment.
And that is by definition almost like not reduceable.
We,
we would be perfectly happy to accept like the definition of a bottle of gas as
the average velocity of all the atoms in it.
You know,
we wouldn't be like,
oh,
you're not really describing that accurately because you haven't described every
atom and it's philosophy and its components of atomic protocols.
But we would never accept,
uh,
a similar abstract description of our own consciousness because it is the full
feed.
Yeah.
I actually wasn't,
I wasn't thinking of that particular issue.
The desert where not even the sort of the divine omniscience description of the
little bits would,
where does it,
where some the constitute a description of the,
the experiential field.
Um,
I wasn't actually thinking of that point.
I'm not sure.
I think that might be true of lots of cases of immersions,
including ones that as I like to say Kosho ones so that the,
the don't create a problem.
So I'm uh,
I'm not sure that,
I,
sorry,
what was the,
what was the term you just,
uh,
I just like getting,
it's not,
I just mean ordinary standard emergence that's not puzzling in any way.
Like when you get liquidity,
when you put lots of individual water molecules together,
data,
they're not liquid individually,
but they,
liquidity now emerges as we say.
Um,
so I wasn't actually thinking of what you said.
The,
the,
the point that as it were,
the perfect description of full on total experiential field human experience
could never be extracted from the super description of all the little bits.
Um,
I would think,
I don't see that as,
as the main problem.
In fact,
no.
Um,
I don't know what more to say except that I don't really feel that I'm defending
consciousness.
I'm just trying,
what I'm really trying to do is saying people who are very impressed by the
powers of say computers or,
um,
or by the brilliant successes of physics,
many of them have been led to think that there's a problem about being as good
old fashioned realist about consciousness.
I'm just saying to say,
no,
there isn't,
there's no problem.
It's a mistake to think that,
um,
that these,
that computational science or physics or anything raises any doubt about the
reality of consciousness,
verifiable or is it just axiomatic,
the existence of consciousness?
Well here,
I like to,
uh,
a friend of mine called Ned blocker who was at Nyu that some of you may know
this,
he quotes,
he quotes Louie Armstrong at this point when Louie Armstrong has asked what jazz
was.
And he said,
if you got to ask,
you ain't ever going to know.
And that's exactly what I would say to someone who seems to question the
existence of consciousness.
If you've got to ask you it never going to know.
Um,
uh,
there's another,
and I would just say to each of us,
you know what it's like from your own country,
from your own case.
It May,
well,
it may possibly be that when you get someone in this audience looks at this
thing,
which we all agree is green,
that the,
if I could look through their eyes,
I might see what I would call red.
It doesn't matter.
Um,
you know,
what consciousness is from your own role in case I would say.
And if someone persisted and they were close enough to me,
I might give them a kick and say that there's an example for you.
Uh,
it's just so basic.
It upsets me that philosophers have seriously question the existence of this
thing.
Um,
and that,
and if so,
what I'm trying to saying is there's no good reason to do so.
MMM.
All right.
Thanks again everyone for coming and thank the speaker.
Okay.